OK我们进行50张图的测试
来看卡1
卡1ATR3.7
所以离高点的话只有一个ATR
但这个图它还没有回踩21均线
它两次在均线左右进行了一个上下的切换
没有踩均线
它应该能去前高
但是会被砸下来
我倾向卡1的话
我倾向卡1看
而不是买
如果它接近21EMA的话
那我肯定是买
卡2
我们看一下卡2的话
它是一个反转结构
还没有进行多头排列
那我倾向它能够去测前高
卡2还是看
这个地方有可能被砸下来
卡2看不买
嗯
再看细节
卡3
卡3的图的话
它在21EMA这边
进行了一定的停顿
嗯
不知道
看
如果它能够重新回到21EMA上去的话
那我肯定会嘛
卡3看
卡4
OK
卡4的话是第一次回踩21EMA
然后高点是在6天之前
那如果能在21EMA这边进行稍微的盘整
是可以继续冲的
卡4的话我估计也是看
嗯
我们看一下
卡
卡6了对吧
卡6这个图
感觉震荡比较
嗯
多
它还是一个反弹
卡6看
卡6RS比较低
我不会做
嗯
这个图不够紧
卡7的话
它也是
嗯
卡7它是个高ATR的股票
两次冲顶
嗯
然后第一次回踩
20EMA
卡7
我倾向于不买
嗯
卡8直接跌破21EMA
卡8不买
卡9
卡9看着还行
卡9我可以考虑
嗯
买
我再看一下哈
卡9我考虑买
嗯
卡10
这种
嗯
不是多头排列的
特别是跌破50均线
然后又重新拉回来
呃
卡11的话
我们看见这个股票很慢
温和ATR2.2
然后他在50和
呃
50和这个
50和21均线这边进行了一个缠绕
呃
很难判别它的方向
卡11我也不买
呃
卡12的话
我们来看一下
卡12
ATR3.7
卡12看看
卡13
ATR2.2
嗯
第一次回踩
也没均线
嗯
然后
我看一下
也卡13也是看
但是它的RS线比较高
我请向他去测试前高
呃
卡13
不是我做的票
嗯
但是我估计可以是个买
偏看看
或者偏买
卡14
OK
直接跌破21
也没
那我绝对不买
卡15
呃
这种图也是这种
不是多头排列的图
然后之前有暴跌
我也不会买
卡15不买
卡16
有这个图乱七八糟的
然后
ATR
又那么高
是个波动很高的股
卡16
我也绝对不会买
他关键不买的原因是
他不够
TIGHT
他的盘整不够
盘整不够的话
很容易被扫去
扫来扫去
卡16不买
卡17
诶
多头排列
然后的话
嗯
有前高
但是现在还没有回踩
21EMA均线
他其实是可能是沿着10
10天的均线
在一直在走
嗯
高点在一天之前
卡17
也是看
在这个节点上看
但我觉得他还会出新高
卡18
嗯
同样的道理
他是比较温和的ATR
然后
又不是多头排列
我也不买
卡19
OK
ATR 2.5
他多头排列
但是21EMA是
直接跌破的
那他接下来
然后现在在50均线上
进行了第一次回踩
那大概率他要在20和
21和50之间
进行盘整
然后再拉上去
我觉得他会再往下跌
超过
一个ATR吗
我不觉得会
但是说
他能够回到
两个ATR的位置呢
也许可以
卡19
看
卡20
6.1的ATR
嗯
卡20
稍微有点难
不是我
喜欢做的股票
嗯
我也不买
因为他没有那个
因为他才刚刚
嗯
刚刚跌破了50和21均线
然后重新拉回
嗯
他可能还需要再盘一段时间
卡20
看不出来
不是特别想买
卡21
卡21的话
也是一个
2.1
ATR的股票
第一次回踩
嗯
也没均线
卡21
还是看
嗯
20天之内
他能不能回到高点
很难说
我倾向他是可以的
嗯
但不是我特别想买的票
卡22
OK
卡22的话
简单
不买
50和20
不是多头
排列
嗯
这个票比较慢
卡23
这个图太震荡的
这个图不够紧凑
不在一个多头趋势里面
也不买
卡24
的话
嗯
20天前的高点
之后马上下杂
嗯
那他还需要盘整
你说他要在
接下来20天能重新回到高点吗
嗯
我觉得
有点难度
卡24
也不买
卡25
卡25的话
3.3的ATR
他跌破了21
也没均线
他还需要盘整
嗯
卡25
也不买
卡26
嗯
卡26的话
第一次回踩ATR
嗯
回踩21
也没均线
是错了
嗯
卡26也是看
不是特别确定
他在一个多头趋势里面
但是还没有上冲的那个劲儿
卡27
OK
卡27的话
嗯
他需要盘整
他在50
50和20下
50均线下方待了这么久
嗯
他需要再等一等
才能够往上冲
嗯
卡27看
卡28
也是一个
DATR的图
嗯
卡28也不是特别想买
他进行多头排列了
这是一个好事情
如果能再缩一段的话
他会进行一个像VCP一样的心态
嗯
卡28可看可买
卡29不买
卡29他第一次冲高回落
第一次回踩21也没均线了
嗯
还需要盘整
卡30
嗯
哎
卡30
21和50刚刚在一起
卡30可能可以买
嗯
他需要盘整的话
卡30
偏
可以买
一点点
卡31
嗯
卡31也是一个高ATR的股票
他第一次冲上21EMA
嗯
不
还不是特别够盘整
我倾向他
他不一定能够中到再回踩高点
卡31看
因为因为因为因为
!
因为因为
因为
!